with the full royal arrival Megan was
back in front of a barrage of flashes
holding on to Prince Harry but happy to
smile for the cameras it is the first
time that we've seen her since they
announced they want to step away from
royal life as Megan took center stage
she wanted to bring the focus back to
the achievements what you could call
Harry's military family I will say when
we were watching the videos all the way
in Canada we had the same moment as you
do with Harry confirming he won't be
walking away from events like this
though I feel incredibly lucky to be
able to count myself as one of you and
I'm deeply proud to have served among
you as Captain Wales a lot of you
tonight I've told me you have my back
well I'm also here to tell you I've
always got yours it was two months ago
that we last saw Megan in public their
visit to Canada house maybe a hint of
what was coming the next day they
announced they wanted this new
independent life and while Megan was in
Canada
Harry was left to deal with the fallout
which has overshadowed the work of his
family including the last day of William
and Kate's tour of Ireland some of the
photographer's had their ladders here as
early as last night to get the perfect
shot shows that they are still very much
a couple in demand which does make you
wonder how exactly they're going to get
that perfect balancing act between being
high-profile public figures but also
being able to fully protect their
private life even a proposal wasn't
enough to distract from the couple at
the moment their engagements over the
next few days are likely to be their
last official royal outings as they
prepare for their own new start Rhiannon
Mills Sky News in central London